[Music]
people aren't naturally equipped to deal
productively with difference in fact
psychologically neuro neuro
scientifically psychologically socially
we're very wired to fear and to retreat
from the other or the different and it
takes an intervention of some sort to
promote the openness mentally if you
throw highly different highly diverse
highly divided people together without a
framework or without some sort of
bonding experience first it can have the
opposite of the intended effect and
actually cause more of a clash more of a
feeling of discomfort and ultimately
more authorization between those divided
peoples so some of the things that can
break down those barriers when you bring
them together are things like awe so
there's a there's a fantastic
neuroscientist out there by the name of
dr. Boll Otto who I believe you all have
have spoken with before he's done some
interesting work on how things like awe
or how things like play can cause people
to let go of their fear and let go of
their anxieties so that they enter a
mental state where they're capable of
being curious and entertaining a new
experience or you know maybe it's it's
having some sort of shared trial or
tribulation that Bond's you before you
actually deal with the difficult issues
there's a really fantastic commercial
about a year ago that I think Heineken
put on where it showed two very
different people what the audience knew
to be very different people building a
bar together and just talking with each
other and struggling to build this bar
and then once the bar is constructed
they realized that they were they held
wildly differing beliefs whether they
were differing political beliefs or
maybe some some prejudices towards each
other they weren't even aware of and the
commercial revealed this to them and
then asked if they wanted to sit down
and have a drink together now that they
knew about this divided and since they
just spent that previous hour toiling
over the building of the bar and getting
to know the other person as a human
being before they got to know them as a
set of of tribal political beliefs they
they all sat down and shared a drink
together and
and bonded it's important to take the
time to have an icebreaker moment before
engaging in that conversation and before
jumping right into the hot topics that
are going to make an individual inclined
to jump out of their seat and stop
listening and start fighting so begin
with a dinner begin with a meal begin
with literal breaking bread and and
asking questions of each other in a
personal context that help you get to
know the other individual as a human
being some of the other icebreakers that
neuroscience and psychology are showing
are productive and facilitating active
listening and an open mind are things
like humor so taken some some humorous
content or some all inspiring artistic
content or go do something active like
go for a hike go for a walk
studies show that engaging in nature or
going through some sort of tribulation
even if it's it's something as minimally
challenging as physical exercise
actually helps break down some of the
the mental barriers we have between us
and and then begin to ask questions I
think around the difficult topics we're
looking at huge complex intractable
problems in our country today we're
talking about a broken criminal justice
system we're talking about a broken
immigration system we're talking about
healthcare we're talking about free
expression in the digital age these are
not things that any one person has the
answer to and anybody who says they they
have the absolutely right answer is
probably trying to tell you something or
has the self-interest that you might
want to be a little bit skeptical of
we're going to solve these problems by
coming together across divides and
having conversations with anyone to do
good and no one to do harm and to look
forward and discuss possible solutions I
become deeply concerned when those
conversations are not possible
[Music]